il ya six mois ce pont dire pin a été
détruit pour retenir l'avancée des
troupes russes vers kiev 40000 personnes
l'ont traversé à pied dans le froid dans
des conditions dramatiques certaines y
ont perdu leur vie aujourd'hui alors que
la guerre se poursuit dans le sud et
l'est du pays un nouveau pont est déjà
en construction les ruines du précédent
elles qui sont devenus un symbole de la
résistance ukrainiennes vont rester
intact et vont être transformée en
mémorial
c'est un symbole de vie et de mort de
l'avis de ceux qui ont été sauvées et de
la destruction que la russie a causé à
l'ukraine la ruine et
nous avons sauvé beaucoup de gens ici
nous avons évacué des blessés graves et
des personnes handicapées et pendant des
nuits les unités militaires les armes et
les fournitures ont été transférés vers
les nouveaux fronts
dans la ville dire qu'ils nous les
stigmates des combats sont encore
largement visible le mot d'ordre est à
la reconstruction
que ce soit pour les commerces les
habitations ou encore les
infrastructures
l'objectif est de faire revenir les
familles
chaque mois de plus en plus de gens
reviennent
je crois que 75% de ceux qui sont partis
sont retournés à irvine et en septembre
il y aura une nouvelle vague à cause de
l'école de la reprise de l'éducation
les immeubles les plus endommagés vont
être démolis sur les murs de certains
d'entre eux comme celui qui est derrière
moi les syndics ont affiché des appels
aux dons pour lancer de nouveaux projets
immobiliers alors que l'avenir reste
incertain
voilà pour moi